patrick welcome back
it's uh it's been a while because you
were in a you went to boston i went to
yeah i went to worcester
for a rehab
yes
tell me about that
okay um i went to teen challenge
here we go like i got to get into the
well you've been to teen challenges we
go from talking to to here we are um
yeah i've been to teen challenge
i spent years i spent years uh in that
program
and went back we talked about it in
march i got i was contacted by a good
friend that was there and
made the decision to go back
[Music]
so i was in teen challenge in worcester
through july
from april uh through july
um and wound up wind up leaving after
three months in the program
um
i was supposed to be there for six
months and i think
i don't want to get too much into like
what happened but i we let's just say we
had a difference of opinion on uh
how to help
people with it with addiction problems
um
that being said i love them you know
the people
uh have good intentions um
so
so yeah so i left uh middle of july uh i
wound up leaving um
sort of spur of the moment you know i i
had made the decision or was coming to a
decision that uh i wasn't going to stay
for the entire six months
um
just because i did i i honestly was
starting to feel like it would
probably be better for me not to be
there um
the day i left that wasn't the plan you
know there was like a disagreement that
i had that was
rather extreme um and so
i thought so we left um
i had to say this you know what was uh
frustrating to me after
was because i had no intention of
getting high no desire
it's very sheltered that in there i'm
comfortable with all that i i it would
be true to uh
like i'm institutionalized you know i i
did a count uh while i was in there
that was my 21st rehab i counted them
counter number wrote them down
um
so for me to be in that environment
which is very sheltered restricted no
access to the outside world no phone no
internet tv and
uh i can roll with that you know like
like part of that was comforting you
know and uh
if i was willing to
stay in that sort of a position
forever i probably would stay clean
forever you know but i'm not i'm not
willing to do that that's interesting
right you know to like
if you want to lock me in a closet here
and i'm i'm willing and you just feed me
yeah and i'll
get high i'll be locked in the closet
without you know it's like i'd rather
uh
i'd rather go down
chasing freedom or or you know i mean
like believing that freedom and if
complete freedom is possible then
stay clean because i'm restricted in
that way right
so it's a little bit of all that
but
literally the first
from the first night of being out of
there
the desire to get high
which was just like what the heck is
this you know i don't know
i don't know what i don't know if it was
i don't know if i i i i believe in i
strongly more and more believe in
the uh
like what happens in my life or in our
lives is like a result of what we think
you know and i've been
sort of analyzing and questioning
and i believe that some sort of a change
in my thinking is is
what needs to happen if i'm going to
overcome this permanently and uh
if there was something about hey if you
leave this place you're you're uh
you're done you're screwed you're gonna
die kind of kind of there was like
something about that like in me
you know because i felt it it was like
like it was like i described it like i
was wearing a heavy blanket that night
you know and i was
safe you know i was with
i was with a friend who loves me you
know i have friends in that area
people came to my
i mean it was it was a little bit
humiliating you know i wound up in for a
moment uh
across the street
from teen challenge like with my
suitcase or with my
with no money penniless with with a
phone that hadn't been turned on in
three months that needed to be charged
that for whatever reason i wasn't able
to charge there i had to like leave the
property to do that
plugged into like the outlet of a
chinese fast food
you know
but ten minutes after that you know i
was with people who loved me you know
and uh i was hitting golf balls in a
driving range
just so happens
but i had that you know and
uh
long story short i was getting high a
week later i lasted i lasted a week
and
and got high for
i don't even remember how long a week
maybe something like that
uh
it was
you know it was it was different it was
it was it was like the same but
different um
typically i'm
i'm uh
coming off of so however many months of
of
self being self-supportive working
having you know money and a place to go
vehicles and stuff this time i was like
on foot from the beginning with
barely any money yeah you still have a
job here in l.a
yeah i do so i might so i yeah uh the
job is a leave of absence
situation um
you have a great employer through
october yeah
so that's there um
i was walking around on foot getting
high in massachusetts
you know like
like sort of
begging people for money it's just
humiliating right and and causing
everyone to worry
you know like my family here you know
especially like my parents but
especially my mom for example just
you know my close friends just man this
guy the crap that you put your family
through that's what i i'm realizing
that's what i ate and then the shame
that comes from that yeah that's the
yeah
that's how i just i was telling my
brother like like i still want to get
high like i love the feeling of that
that's not the thing that i
hate
what i hate is
the letting people down the the
irresponsibility um
the the one thing i was a harsh reminder
of
of put i like i like just you know you
know how i well you saw you were
experienced that the whole january
february so that was the most extreme
but that's how that's how it seems like
it works it gets more and more extreme
but putting myself into a position of
having to be completely dependent on
other people
or or having nothing right
um i hate all that
you and i have had a lot of
conversations privately
and
we've talked about how religion might
maybe be the answer yeah and you're more
you're much more religious than i am
yeah but
you know i joke with myself that i i'm
not a believer but
but i think a lot of my
the way i would act would probably be
very much in line with how a very
religious person would
function i try to be
and and maybe is is religion the answer
is is it just you have a
self-destructive streak that's genetic
or something or what do you think the
core of it all is
well
there's a lot of that there's a lot in
those questions um
i don't know i i i believe god is the
answer but but i also think i also think
it's worth defining what you we mean by
the answer and i i've been thinking
about all these things and and and
trying trying to like set aside what
i've always believed you know because
like that's gotten me here or
uh so what are we what are we striving
for like the answer has always been
permanent sobriety right which probably
still is the answer like that would be
but but i don't know if that's realistic
you know like i think i think part of
the uh
the chaos and the like complete lack of
control that i i experience
is because i'm always like
in some way like assuming that's where
we're on we're on this path the permits
of writing and like there's like i'm not
going back to that and then now i find
myself back in that
which was a little bit predictable
and i'm completely you know unprepared
out of control you know like it's a spur
of the moment decision and i'm gone
uh
religion um when you describe yourself
as
as acting like someone that's a
religious person i wonder if you mean
the way you love people or if you mean
the way you are self-disciplined i mean
i mean and like sort of obedient to like
the norms of of uh
coming from adulthood from my dad you
know my dad's
basically atheist and yeah and i think i
get that from him yeah but
i think the wisest saying ever in the
history of mankind is what would jesus
do yeah there's nothing better than that
right guess what it's the answer to
every question you ever have right and
what jesus would always do would be to
show love right exactly and
self-sacrifice forgive yeah yeah accept
all that yeah that's good that's forgive
that's a good one you know i
i'm holding resentments towards certain
things you know like teen challenge for
example or that the way that all went
down and that could have been part of
what brought in that immediate like i'm
going to get high right now
desire
um
i read a bunch of books i had a good
experience i don't want to sound like it
was a bad experience like like for me
especially the first six weeks that i
was there
um
first six weeks i was there i had very
little to do
um so i read a bunch of books and
spent a lot of time praying
and
however whatever people believe about
prayer and about about god um
it it was powerful for me you know and
it's interesting to me that now that i'm
sort of back in the real world so to
speak
uh
i pray way less
quantity
and quality something about
you know i was going every night for
like an hour or two hours because it's
like there's nothing to do you know and
going and being
like in a little room by myself and
and
at some point if you pray like in my
experience if i pray
like if i just keep praying like just
stay at it like now i'm not talking
about every day but like
no it's been 10 minutes i'm not going to
stop like let's just just
at some point like
you know it's like a breakthrough
and all of a sudden i feel
i don't know how to describe it but but
it's awesome right and it feels like it
feels like love and i tend to cry and
but the other part of it is it feels
like things are possible you know like
like overcoming the addiction uh
uh having an amazing life you know
living living in
within like with like healthy loving
relationships with everybody you know
like all these things and and seeing
people seeing others
uh overcome and
and that's what that's always you know
because i like uh
i went to that program probably this is
probably the sixth time i went and
started it and i the last time before
this time was several years back and i
made a conscious decision at that point
uh to not do that one anymore because
it wasn't working like it never like
permanently worked for me even though i
i love it and i love the people and the
friends that i made through that um
but always like especially in the
beginning because it's a it's a
there's a lot of work to do there you
know they there's a lot that they need
to do to keep that keep the program
going which i'm familiar with all that
you know
and there's a you know it takes money to
have these programs with all you people
you know and uh and so it's like a lot
of full-time work is what it is but in
the beginning for me i don't i don't
have to do that and
and uh
i read i read a line in one of the books
it said something about i related to it
and i thought of you and this whole
thing this
this channel and the comments and stuff
it said uh
why is i'm talking about mankind i think
but
why is he so wonderful yet so flawed
you know that uh
that
double nature of us you know and i think
that when i come in here high on crack
and tell you like like we were talking
before about how
the the the the uh
the way of just telling you telling
everybody the truth and what it is is a
little bit of a different thing like now
i'm not i'm i don't even mention i'm
sober at this moment yeah that's gonna
be much harder to be so honest it's
different yeah it's just it's i mean i
think i mean one of the things takes
effort it doesn't really take as much
effort in that right you know you're
very free to talk about everything yeah
you know
but i
i'm a
strong believer in that this total
honesty might be a great way to break
down some of the things that yeah are
blocking us but but you you're the best
example of someone who's been totally
totally wrong and honest yeah and here
you are relapsing we believe that
there's something in it though like my
friend uh my friend felix is the one
that that's
i love felix he's my brother and uh we
uh
we were in boston he's he was at the
program yeah we actually left together
on the same day uh
and uh
we were talking about all this a lot
he's you know we we have a similar
background and a similar time like
experience very very extremely
eerily similar
uh
and uh and we think about this stuff you
know and we we do believe that there's
something in this like like it's all for
something we don't know i don't know
what it's going to turn out to be
um but the the
the total transparency and the the that
there's freedom in that that a lot of us
like probably a lot of us as humans go
through life you know hiding and i
always did and for sure my natural
instinct still is to do that
if people relate it's probably like i i
feel like uh
i'm just saying extreme
example of something that's common to a
lot of
people i think so yeah um
and so like maybe
me coming in here and talking about all
this crazy stuff
people can relate because you know like
and then and they even can be they even
can admire it like oh man i wish i could
i wish i had the courage to be that
honest about whatever their thing is
yeah yeah i'm sure that's going on yeah
yeah
and so with your videos if this could be
helpful um it'd be great if it was
helpful for me and overall i think it i
think it has been um
yeah i feel like an obligation i feel
like a calling or something to do it you
know um
i'm gonna say one one because i wanna
talk about like uh
like the thought processes and stuff and
sure i was thinking about it praying
about it i wrote a bunch of stuff about
all this um
because of what i've always done
and i just grabbed this on the other
videos
going out of my way in most in certain
you know environments to make sure
nobody ever find out you know to really
pretend you know so i i'd have these
horrible
episodes and all what i've been
talking about in here for you know 20
years just doing being like this
crack user
in these behaviors and
then i could clean up
and
go and live life clean for a while and
maybe get a job like this job or go to
school or whatever
and
i'll go out of my way to pretend that
that clean physically sober version of
me is how i always was
you know and so like i would like sort
of
i like perfect the art of like um
lying without technically lying you know
like lying without saying an untrue
statement
and
what i realized uh what kind of came to
me as a thought
along these lines was um
i was trying to take credit myself for
what
what what
god did for me right trying to take
credit for it myself like i'm good
and um
there's one there's one bible verse i'm
going to share if that's okay of course
and it's a it's a popular one because
it's the one it's it's one that talks
about uh
uh paul having a thorn in his flesh
and
and they well the part people always
quote is uh my
because he asked he asked jesus to take
the thorn out of his flesh and and jesus
didn't do it he says i asked three times
and the the quote is my grace is
sufficient for you
for my power is made perfect and
weakness that's the part people always
quote but there's another sentence in
that verse that comes after it says
therefore i will boast all the more
gladly about my weaknesses because then
the power of christ can rest on me and
i was drawn to that part of it i will
boast about my weaknesses and i thought
about like coming in here right and like
i don't boast is the right word i don't
know if that's the same thing but talk
about my weaknesses like because i was
making sure god got no credit for
anything good that ever happened before
literally as a christian
you know
and um
so maybe that's why maybe that maybe
there's something in there i mean i was
i i believe that right like if i if if
this really is like a thing that
requires something from god some power
from god
um
whatever that looks like it's overcome
um
then
i want that power and talk and sort of
telling how it is which is
not uh not very successful you know if
you depending on how you judge it
um
so part so from that angle um
i want to keep doing this you know i
want uh
and i sort of made a commitment to
myself to just keep telling the truth no
matter what it is and when i was in
there i was i was daydreaming about like
grandiosity really is what it you know i
remember when i did my
uh
when i did an inventory one time in aaa
four-step inventory
my sponsor
pointed out about that there was a
grandiosity if you know i have ego and
pride and
and uh sometimes i'm not sure if it's
like a vision from the lord or it's just
my ego that wants to that wants to
daydream about being super successful
and all this
um
so so i was i was daydreaming about
coming in here and telling the truth
that it being some awesome thing here we
go and and
and uh
but really really what it was was uh
i got out of there and got high right
away and out you know so
when i went over there in april you know
i had a few days like i left a few days
open before i entered the program i got
hired during those days right so i got
high right before
and i got high right right after
and uh
and
i've been sober this month uh i've been
staying with my mother i've been like
taken care of basically
by my mother who i freaking love right
who's
you know uh she'll do anything for me i
don't i don't know if that's
uh the healthiest thing or not but at
this point i don't really care like like
she's
i mean i feel like myself i feel like a
human i feel like a living person again
and uh
and that's are you happier right now
clean than you were
when you are when you're in the middle
of a
weekend or a middle of a binge oh the
heck yeah oh yeah
totally totally um
but
i know that i still love it you know
my mind's dancing with it with uh now
i'm gonna do it today you know um
i have a golf tournament tomorrow that's
important to me
yeah
and then some things like that but but
but i but one thing that's different
this like right now than in in the past
when i've been clean is that
uh my mind is thinking about doing it at
some point in the future
right is it something to do with
humility because you talked about how
when you start thinking of yourself in a
very good light
that's when you're more prone to
relapsing
and when you see yourself as as
very vulnerable and very able to do this
again
maybe you're less likely to do it that's
there's
maybe
we wonder about that i was talking to my
brother about that on the way over maybe
being more realistic about it is uh
you know i've been i've been doing
something that we always they always
talk about it in like the 12-step
meetings and and so i know about the
concept but i've never really
practiced it or i had a mindset of it
like but like i feel like i do now which
is just today like one day at a time
concept like uh my plan is to not smoke
any crack today
um well i don't really i don't even know
if it's as much as what i'm saying is
like telling yourself you're not going
to smoke crack maybe
reminding yourself that you are
vulnerable and capable of doing that
yeah any day anytime right and maybe by
just
making yourself more having it more of
an aware thing versus like yeah i do
because i get into that where i'm like
buying my own bs right like here i am so
a little more humility might protect
right might keep you from saying all
right i'm good i'm going to go do this
hopefully it does because i do it
probably is a more humble position to be
which i which i want to be you know uh
i have certain friends that are that
that you know i invite to
to be honest with me and and one that in
particular comes to mind like she told
me like dude you need you're not humble
we talked about a couple weeks ago
humility and gratitude
you know my natural thing is ego and
pride um
so
so yeah that's a thing um
so that's where i'm at like like uh
so i'll tell you i want to tell you one
story for sure that i'm saying i was
thinking one thing i do
obviously not when i'm coming here on a
crack in a crack binge but when i'm
coming here sober
the way i think and the way i uh
deal with anxiety i think and and
is to plan everything and i
i sort of like my natural thing would be
to come here with a plan of what to say
what to talk about and how to say it and
and i uh
i was thinking about that yesterday dro
actually drove
my mom lives in arizona i stayed with
her for for a month um
thank you mom i love you um
and as i was driving here thinking about
doing this
my my instinct was a planet but then the
next thought was duh don't plan it
because the more i feel like the more i
plan it the more
it could be like inauthentic you know
like once i start planning it it's like
well why are you playing this because i
care what people think
and i want them to think of a certain
thing versus
here's what happened think what you want
you know
um
i was
like two days into smoking crack in in
uh
taunton massachusetts
knowing nobody walking around just just
you know and i had like a couple hundred
bucks more
coming in or available and so i was
refusing to stop
you know i was living i was living in a
sober living house that i had just moved
into
um
that was like come back you know come
back we're not gonna kick you out you
know like i'm refusing i'm just going
for it
and i'm sort of happy-go-lucky you know
sort of like i don't know like in that
there's a stage of it where it's like
nothing matters
and i'm walking
down the street
and actually i was like standing
and all of a sudden
some beautiful young girl
looks at me like i know you
patrick
from from youtube
out of nowhere
i was like yeah
take my number what are you doing like
hang out you know i'm
and
i asked her like would you do you get
high yeah
i have it come to my apartment
i was excited like in that state you
imagine me in that state like
and
she wanted being
a beautiful person you know like it
wasn't like a
like a like
you know like a street walker type of
thing at all like she had an apartment
and she just happened to
to uh get to get high and she she
welcomed me
and i uh hung out with her and her
friend uh
for a couple days
um
didn't you know didn't have money like
didn't it was was begging my dad to give
me money the whole time which is just
embarrassing
um
but during that during that
those that
um that binge i
tried fentanyl
and uh
someone was doing it you know uh and
i know like that's
and very dangerous you getting that get
into that uh
that desperation
like that like who cares about life
you know and i don't know
just why i didn't care like like that
that oh you might die from it
for whatever reason it's not like i have
all kinds of opportunities to do
fentanyl ever but uh
you know i wanted to be at wine to be a
part of whatever was going on there and
she was doing it
the crack and fentanyl get mixed up
sometimes a lot of people yeah i've
heard that and i've never necessarily
experienced that if if somebody who's
typically smokes crack gets mixed up get
some fentanyl mixed up which happens a
lot
uod iod oh you did i tried i tried it
started like one little thing of it and
um
oh deed ten minutes later wow
dead and uh
she called the paramedics i was revived
by
six shots of narcan
uh
six
yeah yeah i guess i don't know how that
works she had one there and they gave me
five more and uh
yeah and i i didn't know what's going on
but the next thing i know i'm
coming back to consciousness like laying
on the floor handcuffed like a wild
animal
resisting all over the place and
finally after they got me out of that i
sort of came to exactly it hit me like
oh you od yeah you actually chose to do
fentanyl i did yeah i asked if i could
try something that's interesting yeah
that you would be
even open to it right and so in that
moment i was uh
i didn't care you know i i guess i
wanted to be higher i wanted to feel it
i don't know what i wanted you know i
think i think it was more wanting to fit
in but that's why that's almost suicidal
yeah there's a little bit of that
i did i mean i wasn't it wasn't like i
hope i die from it but i didn't it was
like i didn't care you know and i did
say like give me a small amount that
would fend all so dangerous that yeah
that's the thing and if you're open to
trying it you're yeah you're up you're
right you're on the dice yeah and so
that happened um i'm glad that i didn't
die
you know yeah um
sometimes in the situations like that
people don't
uh
necessarily even call you know because
maybe there's drugs involved or whatever
or you're alone if you're alone yeah
that's the thing i always think i always
i feel i figure like when people od on
opiates almost always they're alone
or multiple people both od
you know so
so that happened so the whole thing was
just super dramatic and um
i wound up on a plane back here like a
few days after that
back to l.a
ask a stupid question does that
change the way you think or operate or
anything like that it really doesn't
does it
because again i know there'll be
comments saying oh you know that
fentanyl
like a wake-up call there's a wake-up
call it doesn't work the only thing it
will do and i do believe this is
uh i won't do fentanyl again
yeah and let me i mean like unless i was
literally trying to kill myself but not
for
like the high of it like whatever like
little hive that i experienced before i
went unconscious was unpleasant and
overwhelmingly strong
you know so like
there's no uh oh that was a really good
feeling i wanted to try that feeling
again uh
but even your just your
your usual crack addiction it's not
it's not that you
common sense you're intelligent as
anyone
common
reason and common sense are not going to
straighten you out no that right exactly
it's just not no
you you clearly understand that doing
crack is bad for you but you're not
right that's not going to get you to
stop
there's nothing in the thinking no
there's going to be something
and that's why i was
suggesting maybe a religious conversion
or something
lobotomy anything let me i i'm open to
that like uh i've gone this month um
with that
sort of like let's do it again but like
wait until it's you can
do it
more successfully i don't know under
more control which might just would a
different environment whether
it's not available that might be that i
would read that in the comments that
might you know or maybe a route like
some new obsession like whether it's
exercise or golf or i like or i have
those though you know
um so that's what keeps me straight
yeah like like
i'm obsessed with golf for sure like
i've hit golf balls literally every day
for the last
i got i got golf clubs again i guess
it's only been two weeks but no but you
so you could hit golf call call falls
for six hours and then go smile i'm
gonna miss a day that's the thing is
that there's no obsession and i do
things obsessively that's my nature too
but none of those other things are
have the power of the the the pull like
getting high oh is that right right so
that's the thing of it is that
so it's not like not like a replacement
thing you know it's like i'll do the
i'll do these other healthy things
obsessively
sort of
deep by default because i'm clean yes
this isn't about me but the one thing
that i've always done since i was a kid
is
try to never expose myself to things
that might be right more powerful than
right what i believe is healthy right
like one relationship with one woman or
a
a job that i love or a career that i
that's it i don't need anything extra
right i don't need anything more because
it's because more would be more
stimulating right and perhaps more
addicting or right
it would lead you down a path that's
going to make the whole thing unravel
yeah
like i've i feel like i've been doing
lately the
things people are supposed to do you
know um
and
i believe that it's possible that my
thinking can change
you know like just because
in this moment i have some sort of like
half-baked
reservation or daydream about
smoking crack in a couple weeks or
whenever some future point just because
that's there today doesn't mean it has
to be there always you know
um
meanwhile i'm you know i've been going
to aaa meetings every day
uh i've been writing you know every day
praying like like literally praying sort
of regularly increasingly and
about that like praying about that thing
like the fact that i'm thinking this way
you know
um seeing a therapist
doing all these doing extra sort of
regular secular things that are on the
healthy side
um
so
and if i'm honest like
it's it is losing a little bit of power
that's great there's losing a little bit
of power right but it's there still
right it's there still
it's like it's uh
they talk about it like in the
alcoholics anonymous book about um how
important it is um
to know
like
they use this like this language like
uh
fully concede to our innermost self you
know like there's like we have
we're alcoholic we're addict we're we
have we cannot take a drug or drink even
one
successfully to like know that at the
core of our being
kind of is required
in order to do the rest of the program
you know like you won't do it but the
way it needs to be done unless you have
this starting point of like i know i
just desperate it's like desperate it's
like a desperation position
um
and that
if you don't have that if you have this
sort of idea like well maybe if i could
control it maybe if i like set it up and
told people and planned and waited until
a certain you know then i could control
it which like if i control it that would
be like
stop
before six weeks or something you know
stop like do it for like a few a couple
days or whatever
um
and i'm always in the past been at that
other position of like realizing like
hey it's i can't do it at all
and i feel like i feel like i don't have
that right now you know like that like i
still have this
you know uh
probably delusion right um so that's
that's present
you know and i don't want to hide that
um
but i don't feel like it needs to stay
like that we'll see yeah i mean i think
something
basic in your thinking
might need to probably needs to shift
something like super basic like on the
on the the most basic level needs to
shift so that maybe you'll see things
differently and you you won't even
i don't know it's it's such a complex
thing yeah i don't know either yeah our
talks
you you do with me are some of my
favorites because because we get deep
into it
yeah i i i think a lot i think a lot and
i i would rather talk about
what it happens to me
you know but but i but it's easy for me
to talk about my thinking
but yeah the thinking is that that's the
center of this problem is is my brain
and um
a lot of people
recover
you know yeah it happens a lot of people
do and
i feel like i i know a lot of them like
i have access to them
um
i don't know like i feel like that
that's
in the cards still
this has been a weird year man this has
been a different year
43 43 yeah 43.
yeah
i've thought about writing a book
you know
like i think i was thinking about that
while i was there
yeah because i talked because i came and
we talked a few times and i was it was
it was sort of like uh i think there's
like some shock value to it so i'm like
hey check this out check it out what
i've been doing and it was and i just
tell you the story of like that week or
whatever right um but i feel like my
life has have you know
i've had different like uh experiences
throughout my entire life that are
kind of embarrassing and shocking or
whatever maybe not all negative but
mostly
and uh
that
people might want to read about that if
i was if i had the courage to really
really
write it i think you do have a lot of
courage
yeah so um
[Music]
like i said like i i feel like some sort
of a of a uh
of a connection to this whole thing and
a desire to do it and it would be you
know like a dream like best case
scenario dream is like we document
me getting it
and and uh i'd love to do that
because
because because you know you read books
seems like there's books all over the
place of like the guy that was that was
uh
a gang member on drugs 20 years ago and
he writes the book 20 years later but we
have like we have footage of it like
while it was still happening live yeah
so wouldn't it be awesome like would for
it i'd love to see that you know um
for god to get the credit like because
like really if what you guys have all
heard about me
statistically speaking i'm not gonna get
it
it would have to be miraculous
so let's watch that happen
are you so your plans an hour to go
where
i'm back i'm back in the la area yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna move into a suburb i
need to find a place i'm sober living
most likely
so i'm gonna in the next days i'm going
to be looking at at that yeah moving
into one of those
continuing to do what i've been doing
with
aaa and therapy will you go back to work
yeah good for you the plan is to go back
to work in october yeah that's great
yeah i mean
i'm lucky
you know
like like some some friday night
at midnight you are
thinking of doing something yeah
let's say that happens yeah weeks oh you
know what
i i wanted to last night
and what stopped you
um
the commitments i made to people this
week
like like this not this wasn't the
number one no offense but but uh uh
the golf tournament tomorrow right i'm
going and visiting like one of my best
friends and yeah those are those are
great
up the coast on sunday no but like in
two weeks you won't have those yeah so
so that's what it was last night but it
was still
it was still it was still shaky you know
uh i got into a situation where like
there was an unexpected change of plans
that was sort of out of my control and i
found myself
sort of like
open all of a sudden alone so there was
something there in that
[Music]
on a friday night at midnight in two
weeks
you know i don't know
it kind of i think part of that might
depend upon
what i do before that you know where
where
am i living
who
who else is there you know there's
definitely something to the
getting help from other people
last night i kind of went up and down
um
and then finally because i was thinking
like there's no my brain danced with the
they would have been complete delusion
to think that okay i'll do it tonight
and then still come here tomorrow
and i'm going to play golf right now
it's a practice at this course where we
have this this uh
this turn this big tournament we want me
my my best friend um
we won this tournament last year it's
like southern california wide so we're
the defending champion i'm the defending
champion of a golf tournament believe it
or not and uh we're going to try to
defend our title tomorrow
and i would have just blew that off you
know
if i did that so
no but but after
walking a straight straight line to get
there and doing the tournament yeah you
know and and you got through today and
you got your tomorrow
down the road you it could happen that's
what i'm worried about yeah i know but i
mean like
i don't know i don't really have an
answer to that i mean what happened what
would eventually i mean it would be it
would apply the same
uh
calling somebody like i managed to call
people last night before getting high
yeah you're welcome to call me uh yeah
dude i haven't done it before yeah and
and uh
and
you know but but it also is true
and this is this is kind of like where i
don't fully believe in that um
because
it's already better before i make the
call
you know what i mean like like the
decided to make the call isn't like what
stops it from happening deciding to make
the call is the result of it's not gonna
happen right it's already like okay i
got through it it's not gonna happen the
humility thing that we talked about
earlier could that be
effective you think
i hope
yeah if you if you
if you had a timer on your phone you did
it every three hours throughout the day
just call people like no no no just just
remind yourself that you are
oh that i'm vulnerable that you're
vulnerable that you're capable of
yeah
i yeah i mean i don't know i'm just i
really don't know that's an interesting
concept um
[Music]
you know because you mentioned you have
a tendency to start thinking that you
know yeah especially you know you got it
covered yeah i do and i don't think that
at all so maybe there's something to
that maybe i can just keep on
uh
staying clean today
yeah i
i have uh
you know
no
no there's no there's nothing i mean
that thing so i could do it for
permanently yeah i think that's
what i'm talking about is like so you
had this little talk today and you had
time with your brother and then you have
a golf tournament tomorrow so you're
walking straight straight line walk in a
straight line walk in a straight line
you're doing great you're doing great
you're doing great and
then you
you just can't do it anymore
that's what i'm that's what i'm afraid
of yeah i mean that's a that's that's
realistic i hope you get past it and
yeah right because at some point you got
to get past that because that's always
going to be that's good that's that's
really like just a different way of
saying the whole thing like at some
point it's going to happen yeah yeah
it's going to happen but see what my
mind and again we'll see if this is
delusional or not is thinking like what
if it happens but it's just not super
destructive
you know
that's the
score sort of dangerous
dance well you're having you're more
clear-headed and cogent than you've ever
been
today
at least as i've seen you that's true
yeah for sure and i feel like i'm i feel
like i'm probably
more comfortable in my own skin than
i've ever been yeah you've seen it and
thank you for that like that this this
whole thing has been part of that
um uh
probably going and being a teen
challenge and being back in like a
sort of deep level
spiritual
uh discipline thing at this at my sort
of advanced age compared to before maybe
helped with that
um
you know
not caring so much what people think
being willing to be
yeah
you're you're you're such your story is
going to be really interesting to get to
the bottom of because right you're
clearly so charming and intelligent and
handsome and you have all these great
qualities great sense of humor all these
things
but you're still gonna
you know i'm hoping you never do but
yeah you're still gonna [ __ ] it all up
yeah again probably or maybe you have in
the past i always have yeah right and
it's like yeah
so so yeah knowing that you have so much
to lose isn't enough
no
and that's frustrating for me to watch
and and and that's another thing that's
the lack of desperation and i'm honestly
i'm just gonna be honest about that so
the most horrifying thing you said in
this whole talk is that you tried
fentanyl yeah i heard that i'm like oh
geez yeah even more serious than i
thought i tried it yeah
that thing
so
yeah like i think i i think one thing i
wanted to say i don't think i said it is
that i
understand nothing
no
i don't i really don't understand for
some uh
there's wisdom in that i think
wait i spend way too much time thinking
to understand so little as i do thinking
about reading and writing and i
i think there's there's i don't know
genius or wisdom in
knowing that you don't know yeah
and you're never gonna know
maybe not uh and that's maybe the
humility that we talked about earlier
yeah that's that's sort of like my
summary statement of this year i suppose
i i don't know
and but uh
but i do i enjoy
the feeling of being sober right now
you know yeah yeah like i'd like to
to come down here to do what i you know
plan on doing i have some stuff to take
care of this week this is like my first
sober moment in la really kinda
since december is being in l.a difficult
for you no not so far um
no
that might be not that might not be the
right answer i'm with my brother like
that's i'm okay right now
um the thing last night i was out in
riverside when that happened but it's
everywhere
you know it's everywhere no
um crack is everywhere
yeah you can go to north dakota i have a
car in my own car again so i can
you know
i mean i'm growing up i can do you know
if i want to blow it off i can you know
it's going to come down to that like
that's ultimately this is you know it's
going to be me
that either does it or doesn't do it
anymore
yeah
i hope you never do yeah
me too but you're welcome to come in
here any at any time dude i want to keep
doing this i don't know i feel called to
it and i feel like uh
if nothing else let's let it be a a
research for everyone like here i am or
whatever that's what my whole channel is
it's just just so we can all
learn and listen and understand a little
better yeah that's the only reason i'm
doing yeah
and if anyone gets anyone who gets
anything out of it good if you if you
hate me okay like
everyone's got something somebody told
me something beautiful she said uh we're
all just walking each other home
oh that's great you know and uh
yeah i love that
all right patrick mark thanks good luck
tomorrow thanks kick ass i'll let you
know yeah
and we'll do many more hopefully awesome
thanks thanks
you